si tu veux boire ou loana ou pas fait
quelque chose
j'ai déjà extrêmement heureux qu'elle
soit là parmi nous mois loana je suis un
peu ému parce que j'aime beaucoup je lui
ai tendu la main plusieurs fois j'ai pas
compris mais j'ai appelé et il m'a tout
je sais pas si tu l'as dit mais c'est
une partie de mon histoire aussi donc
quand tu es pas bien envie d'embêter les
gens je sais je suis un peu comme toi
mais parfois il faille similaire
plusieurs reprises à trois fois juré pas
quoique trois fois j'ai tendu la main
jeudi roman jeta que chez moi je ne
voulais pas que sneijder et l'italie
mais oui mais au final j'aurais préféré
que tu viennes avec moi tu vois que que
voir des gens comme comme l'auteur sait
plus comment savoir l'agente conclura
par la liberté pure pas mais en tout cas
je suis ravi car il nous a dit elise est
enfin y faisait part drummond je suis
ravi car il s'occupe de sa maman aussi
mieux on pourrait passer à un moment où
la fatigue et 8e la bienvenue parce que
franchement ça m'a tellement blé se fait
ou on a que j'ai vu les mésaventures et
messieurs et mesdames c'est bilingue je
vois cool et je ne peux rien faire d'ici
la fin de l'année on passe un week-end
ensemble tu me le jure je te le jure je
lui rappellerai si ce sera le bienvenu
et est géré à vis atteint ça tapait
nickel n'ai pas de nouvelles de l'onac
et répondent pas tat message
mais ce qu'il ya c'est que j'ai toujours
été bien menée envers loana s'est on a
vécu des choses incroyables l'ofs le
défilé jean paul gaultier
on a fait des sens elle est déjà venue
au mans en plus on j'avais invité un
week-end au monde donc c'est quelqu'un
pour qui j'ai énormément de steam donc
au début je me suis même pas j'ai bien
vu que sur le tard il a vendu est un peu
énervé après c'est pas que j'étais
énervé c'est ce que j'ai dit que j'étais
blessé cam répond pas parce que je vois
s'enfoncer sans français alors que moi
qui suis une main sincère parce que j'ai
rien à gagner
je fais vraiment parce que je laime pas
pour des raisons x y ou machin ou bidule
c'est parce que je veux l'aider
donc quand je vois ça que je suis
impuissant et que je la vois toujours
coûts les plus bas et j'essaye de la
rattraper qu elle m'échappe
quand on aime vraiment quelqu'un ça fait
de la peine je suis ravi que tu sois là
ce que mon affection est indéfectible
mais on passera ce week-end luan à ce
que tu as fait le tri dans ses relations
oui bien sûr alors réalisé 70% de son
nez ou avec sylvie ortega non c'est
parfait parce que j'ai vu que vous avez
essayé de contacter non non j'ai fait un
envoi groupé d'un brin de muguet sur le
premier but oui et elle était encore
dans ma liste c'est ce qu'elle a reçu
mais je ne parle plus assidus dia ortega
depuis depuis 2 depuis la sphère de
l'histoire de des médicaments alors elle
a dit on voit la capacité de ça fait des
mois là que je lui parle plus alors est
là mais elle a mis un mot allah dit
lohan à risque d'être invité demain
sûreté pmp je préviens direct une seule
accusation une seule insulte aux travaux
des gars je veux des places directes à
nice chez sa mère et je fais tout en
sorte que cette fille se fassent
directement internet via le procureur
naïma et je suis pas chez ma mère parce
qu'elle voit de l'airé chez ma mère mais
comme un petit garçon du latex et c est
ce que c'était à ta région rejettent je
pense et ça s intelligente cette
réaction de sa part
à quel point elle est en relation avec
moi je suis fidèle du cabba chez ma mère
est ce que tu veux mais je peux pas
faire des institutions monsieur je veux
dire je ne suis plus en relation avec
elle
d'accord on ne s'écrit plus je ne veux
plus avoir de jamais de ma vie
ben moi je suis ravi que 48 niscota
rompu ses liens avec fred cauvin ton ex
oui terminé hoodrych termine est finie
et si aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
autant d où avec ton pote gilles room
c'est nicolas nicolas blin nicolas voilà
nicolas avec qui tu étais quitte à
cannes ça va maintenant
si vous étiez un petit peu brouillé tu
étais parti de cadres mais non
soc 18 comment comme des amis se discute
drass toujours mon bébé 1